[Aplausos]
[Música]
vengo a compartirles cuatro hábitos
simples bien simples
para ganar
antes de empezar me gustaría hacerles
una pregunta a cada uno de ustedes y
antes de la pregunta me gustaría
llevarlos a un punto en donde eligen una
meta por favor si me pueden hacer ese
favor de cualquier tipo en su mente una
meta puede ser personal profesional
laboral espiritual de cualquier tipo
eligen una mente ya la tienen perfecto
la pregunta es para esa meta que
eligieron y ojalá seas una de sus
mejores metas desde su top 3 cuántas
probabilidades creen que tienen para
lograr esa meta del 0 al 100 por ciento
en el ser obviamente son nulas
probabilidades y tienes todas las
probabilidades del mundo del 0 al 100
eligen un porcentaje
ya lo tienen perfecto guárdelo con
ustedes
la siguiente pregunta solamente le
aplica a todos aquellos que pensaron que
tienen menos del 100 por ciento
y es que es aquello que te está
deteniendo para no alcanzar ese 100% que
es factores que aspectos que es aquello
que te hace falta que no tienes que te
está deteniendo piensa en esa respuesta
y por favor guárdala contigo y la
tercera pregunta es
cuál es esa frase palabras refranes que
te caracterizan a ti a ti mismo que
cuando lo piensas o lo dices te mueve a
la acción
cuáles son esas palabras o esas frases
que a ti a ti en lo personal te
caracterizan y cuando las piensas y las
dices te mueves a la acción das el paso
a blas lo que tienes que decir alzas la
mano y guárdalo contigo por favor
cuatro hábitos simples para ganar
entonces
vamos a empezar aquí nos están poniendo
la presentación y para esto he diseñado
una fórmula
todos hemos escuchado muchas fórmulas
para ganar entonces esta forma esta
fórmula y estos aspectos a mí me han
funcionado bastante y por eso se los
quiero compartir
el primer aspecto de esta fórmula es una
postura poderosa una postura poderosa
esta es la fórmula
si la quieren decir a la mejor para que
no se les olvide la vía no la tía la vía
el primer aspecto es una p es postura
poderosa y para esto me gustaría
pedirles un favor a todos que si se
pueden levantar de sus lugares unos
segundos por favor nos podemos todos
levantar unos segundos les agradezco
bastante y lo que vamos a hacer lo que
vamos a hacer es precisamente una
postura poderosa todos elijan a su
superhéroe favorito y vamos a hacer yo
aquí mi superhéroe favorito todos lo
pueden ver es superman entonces vamos a
hacer juntos eligen una postura poderosa
y la vamos a hacer juntos todos por
favor entonces vamos a aclarar esto es
esta es una este es un ejemplo de que
estamos en tiempo real
y todos por favor vamos a hacer
la postura poderosa por favor me
acompañen todos les quiero decir que
basado en un estudio de la universidad
de harvard en estos momentos lo que está
sucediendo dentro de ustedes
bioquímicamente lo crean o no lo crean
es que su testosterona seas hombre o
mujer está incrementando en un 20% la
hormona del cortisol qué es la hormona
del estrés está disminuyendo en un 22%
por lo tanto este estudio científico
demostró que las probabilidades que
tienes para ganar y lograr lo que
quieres se están incrementando en estos
momentos en un 33 por ciento imagínate
qué hábito tan simple que si lo hacemos
nos va a funcionar bastante les
agradezco a todos se pueden sentar muy
amables
si alguna vez han escuchado la serie de
grey's anatomy
amelia software antes de empezar a hacer
algo lo que hace es precisamente postura
poderosa porque ella está convencida en
el estudio científico realizado por la
universidad de harvard de que
efectivamente funciona entonces es algo
tan simple incluso antes de ser
presentado y entrar aquí yo estaba
haciendo mi postura poderosa ahí no sé
si alguien me vio pero estaba así
y si funciona de función véanme
bueno muy bien muy bien el siguiente
hábito de esta fórmula a la siguiente p
palabras poderosas y les quiero que
traer aquí una una breve historia de
estas palabras poderosas
el que vende su lado izquierdo
se llama el señor burns el señor burns
resulta que él tenía un gran deseo en su
corazón y él quería ser socio del gran
inventor thomas alva edison pero él no
tenía dinero entonces el andrajoso y
todo sin tener dinero se fue en un tren
de carga al despacho del señor edison
que es el que está a su derecha se fue
en un tren de carga y cuando llegó las
palabras que pronunció es señores y son
buenas tardes vengo a hacer negocios con
usted con usted quiero ser su socio
todos los que los que lo estaban
escuchando en el despacho de edison se
rieron a carcajadas de él el único que
no se rió fue edison desde luego que en
ese momento pues no lo conocía le dio
una escoba y le dijo pues ponte a barrer
a que mi despacho al paso del tiempo
cuando él hizo el desarrollo su edison o
su equipo de ventas su propio equipo de
ventas no confiaba en él entonces el
señor burns que andaba ahí en el
despacho levantó la mano y le dijo tú si
me da chance
vamos hablando los años 1900 más o menos
yo me voy a promocionar el punto es que
fue exitoso al final del día lo que ven
allí a la derecha y lo que está en
círculo rojo es como se promocionaban
los el comercial de lo que vendían decía
hecho por edison instalado por barnes
imagínense es decir cuál fue su palabra
poderosa señor edison quiero ser su
socio vengo a hacer negocios con usted
estás loco qué verdad o sea si ni te
conozco entonces sin embargo la clave de
la palabra poderosa es que puede ser
cualquier palabra pero tiene que estar
alineada con el deseo de tu corazón esa
es la clave no importa no hay una
palabra fija o
algo que digas esta es la que tienes que
decir no es te va a salir a ti pero ojo
tiene que estar alineada con el deseo de
tu corazón y entonces con eso incrementa
sus probabilidades de ganar este es el
siguiente hábito esto que ven aquí ahora
los quiero llevar al aeropuerto de
johannesburgo en sudáfrica en una
asignación que tuve de trabajo
imagínense el área de los baños me
acercaba yo a entrar y en la puerta
había un conserje
y entonces pues no era el único éramos
muchos que pues nos dirigíamos al baño
entonces al momento de entrar este joven
nos saludaba a todos de esta manera
welcome to my office dice sanz alonso
fish bienvenido a mi oficina esta es una
hermosa oficina claro que era inevitable
a veces que no te rieras pero el lugar
más subjetivo cuál era su objetivo que
le dieras una moneda una propina
entonces cada quien usa en sus palabras
para lograr sus objetivos pero si usas
palabras claves alineadas con tus
objetivos vas a incrementar sin lugar a
dudas tus probabilidades de ganar ahora
bien ahora los quiero llevar a un
experimento social que hice porque esto
del estudio de la universidad de harvard
de superhero post está muy bien pero yo
dije a ver quiero preguntarle a la gente
qué piensa de sus probabilidades de
ganar en la vida y a un gran número de
personas les dice las primeras mismas
tres preguntas que les hice a ustedes al
principio se acuerdan de esas tres
preguntas se acuerdan de las respuestas
las tienen en su mente cada quien verdad
bueno lo que vamos a ver es en este
experimento social que realice que nos
dijo la gente
y esto es un promedio no hay nombres es
un promedio
y ante la primera pregunta de cuántas
probabilidades crees que tienes de
alcanzar lo que quieres
el promedio nos dijo que el 87 es decir
no hay un 100% en el promedio que es
aquello y fue la siguiente pregunta que
te está impidiendo que tú sientes que
tienes el 100% son estos tres estas tres
cosas que ven aquí
dinero tiempo y capacidad entonces
a mí me gustaría decir lo siguiente
puede ser que tengas tiempo imaginemos
pero no tengan las otras dos imaginemos
que quieres poner una pastelería no
sabes hacer pasteles pero bueno tienes
tiempo para conseguir a alguien que sí
lo sepa hacer no tienes dinero pero
tienes tiempo para conseguir
inversionistas y convencerlos de que lo
que quieres hacer es realmente una idea
poderosa que te va a llevar a ser un
negocio etcétera tienes tiempo yo les
quiero compartir un aspecto del dinero
cuando estaba en la universidad que van
a decir muchos
y ya tiene algo de tiempo cuando estaba
uno que es chamorro verdad cuando estaba
en la universidad
cuando iba a brincar a mi noveno
semestre lanzaron una convocatoria para
irse de intercambio académico a estudiar
un semestre en el extranjero
si ustedes me hubieran visto en ese
momento el deseo era quiero ir y cuando
volteaba a ver mi bolsillo ni un peso
partido por la mitad mejor un peso
partido por la mitad sí pero poquito va
pero no alcanzaba entonces otro amigo y
yo nos armamos de valor fuimos con él a
la oficina del rector y entonces lo que
dijimos es tenemos un gran deseo
queremos ser los pioneros de esta
universidad tiernos al extranjero y
representarlos
y más cuerdo que se me queda viendo
la persona que estaba ahí se me queda
viendo y nos vio yo no sé si se me habrá
visto con esta postura habré utilizado
palabras en sintonía con mi deseo y al
final del día nos dieron esa oportunidad
porque cuento este ejemplo porque no
tenía dinero y muchos de nosotros creo
creo que hemos estado en situaciones
donde no tenemos dinero y qué sucede nos
detenemos pero ese obstáculo no es
físico es mental solamente está aquí
entonces es simplemente atreverse a dar
ese primer paso
y esta expresión que ven aquí ya me
adelanté un poquito se acuerda la
palabra que les dije que pensaran que de
palabra o frase los movía la acción pues
bueno la que más se repitió en este
experimento social la gente dice que
cuando dice sino su madre para la acción
me muevo no me puedo quedar parado si
nos movemos dada la acción entonces hay
otras frases que también me dijeron muy
buenas que por cierto bueno yo aquí yo
dije oye que poder poderoso el de la
madre de verdad
que poder este entonces hay otras
expresiones también muy buenas que me
hicieron y por qué no
y hay varios muchos fueron muy buenas
hay una que me dijeron en latín que era
yo dije y tú qué dices memento mori qué
significa eso recuerda que vas a morir
que a esta buena base nombre que se me
levanta de la cama ya ahora en liga a la
rueda que se ocupaba como dice entonces
esto es lo que más se repitió pero el
punto es que uno mismo tenga algo que no
se identifique y que nos mueva a la
acción con eso que vamos a hacer
sencillo vamos a incrementar nuestras
probabilidades de ganar la vida está
hecha de probabilidades que no la vida
está hecha de probabilidades porque no
jugar con las probabilidades a nuestro
favor si empezamos a conocer nosotros
mismos y sabemos bioquímicamente qué
está pasando dentro pues simplemente
darnos una ayudadita muy bien
siguiendo con esta fórmula imágenes
poderosas este que ven aquí con mucha
imaginación soy yo un poquito blanqueado
para no decepcionar a mis hijos verdad
porque ellos son de tez blanca fernando
y sal y perdón santiago y fernanda ellos
son de tez blanca entonces pues no no
los quise decepcionar va entonces con
mucha imaginación es este soy yo
van a decir que lo que voy a decir ya
está todo pasado pero yo antes de haber
sido invitado aquí que por cierto quiero
agradecer mucho a los organizadores de
este evento un gran evento por haberme
invitado yo antes de estar aquí yo ya me
visualizaba aquí amanecer ay si yo la
tangana más porque estás aquí yo ya me
veía en el punto rojo era mi anhelo
estar aquí en el punto rojo ante ustedes
compartiendo una idea
y se hizo realidad yo no sabía si va a
ser en esta edición en la próxima en
cinco años en diez años yo decía
jonathan tú ya estás en el punto rojo
hablando idea imagen poderosa créanme se
hace realidad practiquen no nada
perdemos y se hace realidad acción la la
postura a las palabras y las imágenes
suman pero la acción multiplica entonces
siempre es bueno moverse ley de la
certeza la ley de la certeza el que ven
aquí es el señor bilbao arman a él yo lo
hice mi mentor porque de hecho me enseñó
esta ley simplemente yo le agregué un
par de cositas y la ley quedó así ley de
la certeza funciona tal tanto como
cualquier ley natural y dice si tú haces
ciertas cosas de cierto modo durante
cierto tiempo rodeado de ciertas
personas ciertos resultados están
ciertos a ocurrir qué es lo que más se
repite cierto cierto cierta forma cierto
modo ciertas personas cierto es eso
aplica mucho en la acción
la pgje acuérdense no la tía la pía es
la que nos va a ayudar a ganar y por
último no me quiero retirar sin
despedirme de ustedes
con unas palabras que leí del señor
warren buffett uno de los cinco hombres
más ricos del mundo que dice que un
millón de dólares no te va a ser feliz
lo que lo que realmente te va a ser
feliz son tus raíces las raíces son
aquellas que te hacen ser quien eres
imagínate ahora déjame llevarte muy
brevemente a un escenario donde eres un
náufrago y estás en medio de la nada
solamente tú tu lancha y el mar quiero
preguntarte qué es aquello que nadie te
pudiera quitar estando en medio de la
nada que esté aquello tus raíces lo que
dice el señor buffett tus raíces
entonces apeguémonos a nuestras raíces
porque ellas quienes somos nuestra
autenticidad lo decía diego en la charla
anterior quienes realmente somos
nuestras raíces es lo que nos va a hacer
incrementar nuestras probabilidades de
ganar y finalmente por favor la próxima
vez que realmente deseen incrementar sus
probabilidades de ganar no olviden
llevar con ustedes una etapa de
superhéroe muchas gracias
[Aplausos]